[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les colons
je vous souhaite un heureux mariage et
que les mauvais démons s'éloigne des
jeunes époux mme
ibrahima
nous te demandons veux-tu prendre pour
épouse fret y matin
ceci juste à côté de toi
oui je le veux
[Applaudissements]
à que ceux qui sont dehors oui c'est
elle que je veux
[Applaudissements]
fatimata soit consciente que la vie de
couple n'est pas sans difficulté il ya
des jours heureux et des jours
d'amertume
vaty matin toi qui est là en face de
nous il faut que tu suivre le même
chemin côté mer
des mamans qui sont notés papa dans le
respect la paix la stabilité toi aussi
tu dois faire comme l imiter maman
ibrahim a est entré dans l'armée en 2018
en tant qu'infirmier militaire
à la sortie de la mairie les compagnons
d'armes du sergent-chef s'empare de la
mariée pour une session de bizutage
une tradition pour que la femme
s'imprègne des souffrances que subit son
mari sur le théâtre des opérations
contin qui militaire la situation
sécuritaire de mon pays m'inquiète
énormément depuis cinq ans
on a perdu beaucoup de camarades de
suite à de multiples attaques dans
différents postes non quand ça arrive
c'est une tristesse c'est une tristesse
au delà de tristesse à chaque fois que
j'ai l'impression que ça va ça
dégringole ça dégénère encore
personnellement ça m'inquiète
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bamako est la dernière ville du mali
échappant encore à la guerre
pourtant rares ici sont les familles qui
ne porte pas le deuil d'un soldat tué au
front
[Musique]
né d'une et à la radio que j'ai appris
qu'il y a eu une attaque à kaboul
question
tenais bas a perdu son mari le 1er
septembre 2019 le sergent maïga a été
tué avec 40 autres camarades dans une
embuscade tendue par les djihadistes sur
une base militaire du centre du mali
j'aurais aimé me recueillir sur sa tombe
et même y emmener ma fille plus tard
pour lui raconter qui était son père
tout cela me rend très triste
[Musique]
ni elle ni les autres veuves dont vu le
corps de leur époux enterrés dans une
fosse commune non loin de la base
attaqué
depuis tenais bas s'est installée chez
son père avec pour seul héritage les
tenues militaires de son défunt mari
sont google
normalement toutes ces affaires là
l'armée devrait venir les chercher nos
frères nous ne devons pas les garder il
devrait venir et prendre pour les
emporter au camp car d'autres militaires
en auront besoin ça ne peut pas rester
ici à la maison parce que personne ne
les utilisera
[Musique]
ce qui me surprend parce que les bulls
et que c'était des spécialistes c'était
l'unité de commandos parachutistes qui
était dans ce camp de boules quiès y
compris par la cie sont les gens qui est
spécialisée des gens spécialisés comment
ce camp a pu être attaqué mais comment
autant de militaires ont pu être tué le
mari de ma fille était un expert je
n'arrive toujours pas à comprendre ce
qu'il s'est passé
il m'avait dit qu'il voulait arrêter il
m'a confié qu'il avait peur de la
tournure que prenait l'armée
ils s'inquiétaient car j'étais enceinte
et beaucoup de gens perdaient la vie au
front alors partir à la guerre dans ce
contexte en sachant qu'ils pouvaient
mourir salle inquiétait beaucoup
tenema évoque une arme est sous pression
depuis plus de huit ans
[Musique]
tout commence en 2012 quand une alliance
de groupes rebelles et de djihadistes
lance une insurrection pour réclamer
l'indépendance du nord du mali
[Musique]
au même moment à bamako un coup d'état
désorganise la hiérarchie militaire et
la riposte contre la rébellion
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
où
loin de la capitale sur le terrain les
forces maliennes se retrouve incapable
de contrer l'offensive et se font
chasser du nord
[Musique]
le mali focalise l'attention du monde
entier car c'est toute une région le
sahel qui pourrait vaciller sous la
férule des jihadistes
en 2012 marc andré boisvert était
journaliste indépendant à bamako témoin
de la frise malienne il choisit de
devenir chercheur il est aujourd'hui
l'un des rares spécialistes de l'armée
malienne l'art mais c'est fait et c'est
du nord et lui s'est pris toute une
claque sur la gueule
et à ce moment là on a découvert un
paquet de problèmes tant au niveau
tactique
opérationnel que stratégique
donc la faiblesse de l'armée malienne
longue repose beaucoup sur ces presque
trois décennies où le politique fait le
choix de se dire ben voilà puisqu'il n'y
a pas de risque à nos frontières je ne
crois pas qu'ils se sont dit on va
regarder ils vont on va dire regardez
une arme est faible mais je pense que le
choix avait envahi leicester hayart nos
ressources
pour empêcher l'avancée des groupes qui
a dit stosur bamako une coalition
militaire internationale se met en place
à sa tête la france l'ancienne puissance
coloniale lance l'opération serval avec
l'envoi de 3000 soldats
l'onu des fous à six mille casques bleus
à travers la minus marc
denis tu les chercheurs allemands il
étudie depuis plusieurs années cette
coopération militaire d'ampleur qui
engage de multiples partenaires au mali
c'est le mali qui a invité les français
après les européens et les nations-unies
à à venir
au pays et à lui assisté l'idée était
venue de 10 avril il s'agit entre autres
d'un problème de sécurité
et si il ya une solution il s'agit à
établir à reconstruire les formes et les
outils de sécurité et inclut l'armée
malienne
[Musique]
à partir de 2013 l'union européenne
propose aux maliens ont une mission de
formation le utm 800 instructeur et un
budget de 30 millions d'euros par an
pour tenter de reconstruire l'armée
[Musique]
de leur côté les français augmentent
leur présence militaire sur place
l'opération barkan prend le relais de
cerval
mes enfants le mali continue de
s'enfoncer dans la guerre
les opérations militaires sont
concentrés dans le nord du pays alors
pour les éviter à partir de 2015 les
djihadistes migrent vers le centre du
mali
une région minée par la pauvreté les
tensions communautaires ou les
jihadistes n'ont aucun mal à s'implanter
[Musique]
corinne dufka enquête sur les violations
des droits de l'homme en afrique pour l'
ong human rights watch depuis 20 ans
dès 2012 elle alertait sur les graves
abus dont se rendent coupables les
groupes armés au mali
[Musique]
les tensions communautaires ont toujours
existé entre les ethnies au mali
notamment entre les agriculteurs et les
nomades
généralement cela ne durait pas et se
résolvaient à l'amiable
imprimeurs les dates à l'origine ce
conflit portait sur l'accès à l'eau et à
la terre
mais plus récemment les mouvements
jihadistes se sont greffés à la
dynamique des derniers maxime couture et
la crise sécuritaire s'est aggravée
les forces de sécurité sont impliqués
car elle ne protège pas les villageois
contre les attaques des groupes
islamistes
peuvent
parfois ces attaques sont très
meurtriers
le conflit communautaire et le poison
djihadistes plonge le mali dans une
spirale de violence
les maliens sont excédés le président
ibrahim boubacar kéita qu'ils avaient
élu en 2013 est à leurs yeux le premier
responsable du désastre sécuritaire
[Musique]
en 2020 lors de manifestations sans
précédent les maliens réclament sa
démission
affirmant avoir entendu la colère du
peuple des colonels de l'armée renverse
le chef d'état et s'empare du pouvoir
un putsch sans effusion de sang est
acclamée par la rue
mais cette victoire politique des
militaires ne parvient pas à cacher le
profond malaise des soldats du pays car
face à l'ennemi djihadistes l'armée perd
des hommes quasiment chaque semaine une
grogne sourde s'est propagée dans les
casernes et les putschistes la veulent
invisible aucun accès officielle aux
soldats nous sera autorisé
[Musique]
même en échange l'anonymat rares sont
les militaires qui acceptent de
témoigner devant notre caméra ce
sergent-chef engagé depuis 25 ans prend
le risque de raconter la réalité du
terrain nous l'appelons modibo
nous avons terminé avec la formation
commune de base on a été envoyé sur le
terrain à partir de ce moment nous avons
commencé à voir que sur dont nous
rêvions 1 n'est pas réellement trop ce
qui est perceptible dans la pratique
quand j'étais au poste de sécurité
bénéfices en effet environ à 5 km au sud
de kidal et pour un mois de poterie avec
un effectif de 20 personnes vous
retrouvez avec cette arme que vous
passez un trou vous vous imaginez le
commandant aux mets présentés 60 balles
60 munitions
nous utilisons des armes qu'il faut les
six centres anciens coups à la minute
peut pas tenir deux minutes de coma
alors danse de telles conditions si une
attaque se passe vous voyez déjà que
c'est le sauve-qui-peut parce qu'un
militaire sans arme n'est pas et
militaires
ce soldat raconte aussi le manque de
carburant et les véhicules qui ne
démarre jamais
quoi de mieux pour un ennemi qu une
armée et sous équipée incapable de
répliquer en cas d' attaques
depuis plusieurs mois les jihadistes ont
identifié cette faiblesse il s'y
engouffre en s'en prenant aux positions
de l'armée et aux convois militaires
et y tuent des soldats par dizaines
ces images datent de juin dernier elles
ont été filmées par les djihadistes même
dans le centre du pays à 100 km de la
frontière mauritanienne
un convoi militaire d'une douzaine de
véhicules et de 60 hommes heurte une
mine caché au sol
contraint de s'arrêter les soldats se
font surprendre par des tirs c'est une
embuscade tendue par des combattants
terroristes
avec
[Musique]
tout est pillée jusqu'aux chaussures que
l'on arrache directement des pieds des
cadavres
cette attaque a eu lieu dans la région
où sévit le groupe de soutien à l'islam
et aux musulmans un mouvement proche
d'al qaïda ce jour là au moins quarante
militaires sont morts
ces images ont circulé sur les
téléphones de tous les soldats du pays
c'était bien l'intention de leurs
auteurs
aux yeux du sergent modibo ni jihadistes
sont tout simplement mieux organisés que
l'armée nationale
les groupes terroristes ne sont pas
aussi dangereux que ça mais le fait que
eux dans leur dans leurs jaillissements
touché fait dans les règles de l'art et
que de notre côté dans l'armée nationale
la hiérarchie militaire qui détourne
l'essentiel de cet argent qui doit
servir la diriger les opérations sur le
terrain du chef d'etat-major jusqu'au
dévié commandant sur le terrain chacun
fait de retourner à ce niveau et le
détournement est la cause du désastre
macabre la confiance as-tu
la corruption que dénoncent militaire
est un secret de polichinelle au mali
pour autant ce genre de témoignage est
rare
un soir à l'abri des regards nous avons
rendez vous avec un autre soldat qui a
été victime d'un officier malhonnête
il ya un âge un chef et il m'a ordonné
plus les sections et nous allons en plus
abouti les effectifs que je devais
prendre avec ça c'est le départ au
complet c'est incomplet je vivais avec
signal personne mais il m'a donné plus
mordeurs kraft
son chef aurait déclaré 50 soldats alors
qu'il en a envoyé la moitié sur le
terrain il empocherait la solde de
l'autre moitié la pratique serait
courante chez les hauts gradés tuteur
partie intendance une largeur mon solo
je vois sous l'ordinateur chienchien
gratuit vous voyez aucun chef qui me
former après la radiation il m'a utilisé
dans les quatre libérations
c'était pour me mettre le bouger ses
terres pour me faire envoyer tu es vous
est elle est là bas oui
sans être payé sempé
[Musique]
le commandant profite du fait que les
soldats soit en opération pour déclarer
leur radiation
cela lui aurait permis de toucher leurs
primes pendant qu'ils étaient au combat
pour voler le salaire des soldats il
existerait tout un tas de stratagèmes
ans quand
ça va
mon south man touré et juriste à la tête
d'une association de lutte contre la
corruption
il travaille dans un petit cybercafé du
centre ville
récemment moussa a été contacté par deux
soldats
ils ont mis la main sur des bulletins de
salaire falsifiés
les preuves d'un système de double
comptabilité dans l'armée
il ya un bill et inquiets me parler
qu'on seria désarmés dont la somme nette
est supérieure à l'autre au second
billiton qui est émis par des comptables
verrines ou par des officiers supérieurs
la différence entre ces débilités c'est
90 mille francs cfa
ces 90 minutes sont embauchés par des
officiers supérieurs
67 millions d'euros de primes auraient
ainsi été détournés en trois ans après
la révélation de la sphère dans la
presse malienne les deux soldats lanceur
d'alert ont été suspendues pour
violation du secret défense ils ont
décliné notre demande d'entretien et
affirme avoir reçu l'ordre de se taire
quant à moussa il reçoit des appels
anonymes et craint des représailles
je ne m'aime pas là vite et j'ai mené
avant
que je ne parte cette affaire à la
reconnaissance du progrès
souvent il m'arrive même moment
d'échangé des numéros quand j'écoute la
à la maison
en circulation j'aimais méfie beaucoup
je surveille
de partout je me dis se pourrait que je
suis surveillé
oui
la prudence de moussa ousmane touré est
légitime quelques jours après notre
rencontre il a été tabassé en pleine rue
par des hommes cagoulés ils lui ont volé
son ordinateur sur lequel il sauvegarde
l épreuve de détournement
nous aurions voulu parler avec les
autorités militaires de ces révélations
de la corruption qui empoisonnent
l'institution mais là encore aucun
officiel de nous répondre à
opacité détournement des organisations
ces mots sont autant de défis pour les
partenaires étrangers venus aider le
mali
on estime au sein de l'union européenne
40 % des salaires
pour l'armée malienne n'arrive pas à
destination
parce qu'au fur et à mesure de la chaîne
i rachiq tout le monde ou souvent obama
d'officiers prennent des pourcentages
peut estimer qu'il ya un problème qu'en
parallèle armée très en retard sur les
autres administration malienne à savoir
informatisation des drus des dossiers de
ressources humaines et forme et surtout
bank alisation des soldes elle est
vraiment des nombreux temps à combler ce
qui veut dire que c'est une armée qui je
fais pas mal de ses transactions en
argent cash temps qui rappellerait forme
de l'informatisation des fichiers
militaires étant que surtout les sodas
ne toucheront pas leur faute dans leurs
comptes en banque va se retrouver avec
beaucoup
des situations de corruption lui thème
qui est la mission de formation
européenne a mis énormément d'argent
déjà pour qui cette réforme là pour le
moment ça ne toujours pas abouti
et c'est à ce moment là où est-ce qu'on
se peut se poser est ce qu'il n'ya pas
une ride sens plus politique
poser la question c'est déjà y répondre
les dirigeants maliens serait réticent à
tout changement qui viserait à empêcher
les détournements
depuis l'indépendance en 1960 la
mauvaise gouvernance la corruption et la
gabegie des élites mines le mali
le pays sur vit sous perfusion de l'aide
internationale
un habitant sur deux a moins de deux
euros par jour pour subsister
les infrastructures de base font
cruellement défaut le pays croupit dans
l'insalubrité
[Musique]
cet homme est professeur d'université
après une carrière en france clément
dembélé a choisi de revenir vivre à
bamako estimant avoir un rôle à jouer
pour aider son pays natal pour ça sur
mon quartier des eaux vives du
changement
[Musique]
très actif sur le terrain clément
dembélé aimerait que ses compatriotes
respectent les règles à commencer par
l'hygiène publique
jp morgan au matin
vainqueur
ici danser dans cette zone là il n'y a
pas de robinet public les femmes
prennent une autre et dans les maisons
les gens n'ont pas le moins d'accès à
l'eau donc ici j'ai fait un fourrage ici
et qui permet à tout le quartier de ce
côté-là d'avoir accès à l'eau à l'eau
potable
mais ce ne sont pas les forages qui ont
rendu clément dembélé célèbre c'est sa
croisade contre la corruption qui
gangrène la société malienne dans tous
les domaines
son discours dérange en mai 2020 il a
été enfermé durant quinze jours par la
sécurité d'état pour avoir critiqué
l'impunité des politiques et des
généraux malien
en étudiant les budgets de la défense
qui au mali sont confidentielles clément
dembélé a découvert un système de
détournement de grande ampleur on a vu
sur la facture chaussettes anti balles
pour les meubles lll et les militaires
facturé aa pièce aaa à 5000 francs cfa
soit 150 de héros mais il n'y a pas des
chaussettes anti balles ça n'existe pas
on a vu des lunettes des lunettes anti
balles il n'y a pas des lunettes anti
balles consiste quand tu passes et
lunettes mais la balle est nul n'est pas
ce parc
on a vu des gilets pare-balles
anti-balles d'accord mais ces gilets
pare balles ont été achetés en chine et
quand on ouvre les gilets on voit qu'il
ya que du carton des cathos couper des
cartons couper dans l'est et avec des
tissus du sud et on donne ça aux jeunes
militaires pour aller affronter les
terrorise les djihadistes ils se font
criblé de balles parce que c'est du
carton on a facturé ça au prix du gilet
pare balles et quand on a découvert tout
ça mais on a porté plainte les acteurs
de la commission doivent être arrêtés et
qu'on l'a même on remettra aux maliens
ce qui appartient aux manières parce
qu'ils ont volé ils ont pris gens de
tournai le bien public
ces dernières années les révélations de
surfacturation d'équipement voler ou de
matériel défectueux se sont succédé en
toute impunité
l'effet est dévastateur pour le moral
des troupes chargées de combattre les
jihadistes
pour la première fois au cours de notre
tournage un soldat nous confie sa
tentation de rejoindre le camp adverse
mais là
encore au
même
moment
elle s'éteignit lama sera
le bon moment de malamocco feront rouler
à peltre advenir la paix sibomana d'être
de
niamey et bave privé de la cour a alors
contacté binhai de tianjin qui me colle
à 4 mg sable avait d'abord et saint
armand boulot cani
contre la marée noire
bonne soirée à la nature le soir
puisque aucun cas l'accord père fou
d'emma nous attaquer aux fouilles ou tôt
fait de mal et catherine mal choisi le
bois 4 à aline sociale et queen mary 2
était pas me
frustrer épuisé soldats maliens auraient
dû voir leurs conditions de combat
s'améliorer notamment grâce à la
d'étrangères après tout c'était
l'objectif de la mission européenne
mais après huit ans d'existence force
est de constater que les formations de
l'utm n'ont toujours pas rétabli les
capacités de l'armée
il y à cette critique que les formations
sont peut-être pas adapté au contexte
malien c'est à dire vous faites des
formations avec des équipements qui vont
toutes façons n'existe pas au sein de
l'armée malienne et vous vous dites
après débrouillez vous
au final cette mission et surtout le
volet formation n'est pas en mesure
de vous dire quel impact elle a vraiment
sûrs parce qu'il n'y a pas de système de
suivi ces unités arrivent ils
participent à une formation et après une
deux trois quatre semaines ils partent
et la mission perdent toute trace de ces
gens là je n'irai pas aussi loin pour
dire que la situation au mali relève
d'un échec de les huitièmes mais il est
évidemment très difficile actuellement à
mesurer un impact très positive si on
regarde la situation sécuritaire
l'armée malienne a été attaqué dans la
nuit du 12 au 13 octobre à sokoura dans
le cercle de bankass région les mots
petit le bilan provisoire est de neuf
morts et quatre blessés quelques heures
plus tard le renforts dépêchés sur les
lieux est aussi tombé dans une embuscade
ne se passe pas une semaine sans que
l'armée malienne subissant revers sur le
terrain
le bilan officiel des morts deux
disparus et de blessés varie au fil des
jours des chiffres aussitôt oublié quand
survient la sauce suivant
il y à un endroit où ces nouvelles
résonne plus qu'ailleurs
à 15 km de bamako une cité surplombe la
capitale
cathy la grande ville garnison du sud
mali
c'est de là que partent tous les couches
à l'entrée du camp militaire un chantier
attire notre attention
des ouvriers en nombre d'affaires du
matin au soir
- s'arrête pas des faux témoins
mais si tu n'as pas des moindres mobile
et sur ilan et
vous avez construit beaucoup de maisons
ici
il ya beaucoup de militaires mais ça
c'est une maison pour lui tout ça nous
sommes
des habitations trop luxueuse même pour
une seule de d'officier
pour beaucoup de maliens ce sont les
signes extérieurs de richesse issue des
détournements
un peu plus loin dans cathy le décor est
tout autre
[Musique]
voilà où vivent les soldats du rang et
leur famille
[Musique]
des maisons étroites construites en
banco un mélange de terre et de paille
le plus souvent sans eau courante
le quartier ressemble à un bidonville
pourtant nous sommes bien dans un camp
militaire
à cathy beaucoup de femmes sont veuve
depuis la mort de leur mari au front
leur unique réconfort c'est de se
rassembler
[Musique]
dès que nous perdons nos maris leurs
salaires cesse d'être versée au bout de
six mois à durban à quand nos enfants
tombent malades nous n'avons plus de
quoi les soigner nous vendons de l'eau
fraîche pour essayer de subvenir à nos
besoins mais il faut qu'ils nous aident
pour nous en sortir pour dès qu'un
militaire meurt ses proches sont tout
simplement abandonnée
nous sommes toutes des victimes de la
guerre qui a commencé depuis 2012
on a perdu nos maris personne ici n'a vu
le cadavre d'une seule personne n'est
paisible c'est pas là que ici qu'on a
intérêt commun
ils sont tous morts pour la cause de ces
pays la façon dont on nous traite ici c
est nu mais nous ne devons pas être
traitée de cette maille la passionne ne
couvrent pas les dépenses l'éducation
des enfants n'est pas assurée qu'est ce
qu'ils vont devenir des mais ils vont
grandir avec 7 avec ce traumatisme
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire ils ne sont
pas bien loger alors qu'ils sont dans le
pays de leur est il un tel qu'est leur
papa sanctuaire aux morts donc pourquoi
né pas
balkissa vivait à cathy avant de perdre
son mari tué à kidal en 2012
pendant deux ans elle a dû frapper à
toutes les portes d administration
militaire pour enfin obtenir son droit
de percevoir la pension de son mari 180
euros mensuels
depuis elle aide les autres va affronter
le silence et la lenteur de l'armée
comme abibatou une mère de cinq enfants
son mari est mort dans une attaque
jihadiste en avril dernier elle a appris
la nouvelle à la radio
aucun officiel n'est venu me voir
il avait dit qu'il viendrait mais ils ne
l'ont pas fait ils ont appelé mon beau
frère pour lui donner un sac de 100 kg
de mil et 100 kg de riz
moi j'habite est ici dans cette maison
quand mon mari est mort c'est ici que
j'ai fait mon deuil et après ça ils
m'ont demandé de quitter la maison pour
la donner à une autre personne
tu vois tout ça me fait tellement peur
les pensions n'arrivent pas assez tôt
pour se trouver une autre maison
quant aux hommes meurent l'armée devrait
penser qu'ils ont donné leur vie pour le
mali mais ce n'est pas le cas l'armée a
juste en tête d'expulser leur famille
abibatou et ses enfants risquent de
connaître le même sort que balkissa
l'expulsion
malgré les soldats sacrifiés la
situation sécuritaire s'envenime dans le
centre du mali l'état a tout simplement
disparu laissant la place aux milices
qui s'entretuent dans un cycle de
violences nourries par la peur et la
vengeance
face
à la défaillance de l'armée
des groupes locaux se sont constitués en
milice d'auto défense
au
départ il protéger leur village et au
fil du temps ils se sont organisés
ils ne se contentent plus seulement de
défendre leur communauté mais ils
montrent des offensives contre les
groupes islamistes
il se livre à des expéditions punitives
en tuant des centaines de civils
qu'ils accusent de venir grossir les
rangs des islamistes dans le centre du
mans
[Musique]
les violences entre communautés
exacerbée par la montée en puissance des
djihadistes pousse des centaines de
milliers de maliens à fuir leur village
certains trouvent refuge à bamako
[Musique]
voici faladié le plus grand camp de
déplacés de la capitale établi sur une
décharge en périphérie de la ville
près de 3000 personnes s'y entassent
sous les bâches avec les mouches et la
puanteur
[Musique]
dans leur fuite ils ont tout perdu comme
cette femme qui a donné naissance à sa
fille dans le camp
[Musique]
j'ai été réveillé par des coups de feu à
cinq heures du matin ils étaient très
nombreux et venaient de tous les côtés
il était habillé en chasseur
traditionnelle avec des chapeaux à
cornes et des gris gris
tous ceux qui n'ont pas fui ont été tués
cette femme a survécu au massacre de
gossas goût un village peul du centre du
mali ou en mars 2010neuf près de 150
civils ont été tués par des miliciens de
l'ethnie rival les dogons
les dogons accuse les peules de soutenir
les djihadistes ils sont à l'origine de
nombreux massacres que documente sans
relâche corinne dufka
j'ai pu m'entretenir avec des membres de
ces groupes qui affirme que certains
soldats de l'armée malienne leur
fournissent les armes et l'effort
ce n'est pas une politique officielle
mais par conséquent dans les villages
cela est perçu comme un soutien de ces
groupes par le gouvernement et
l'incapacité de l'état à poursuivre en
justice les milices pour les atrocités
commises est perçu comme un feu vert
pour continuer les massacres
la complaisance de l'état envers une
certaine milices et son manque de
volonté pour traduire les meurtriers en
justice contribuer à alimenter un cycle
pervers de représailles sanglantes
les forces armées ne serait pas
seulement complice devant notre caméra
des villageois racontent avoir vu des
militaires brûler leurs villages et tué
les habitants
[Musique]
comme ce bergers peuls arrivée dans le
camp une semaine auparavant
j'étais en train de courir et des
militaires m'ont poursuivi
et puis ils m'ont attrapé m'ont frappé
ils m'ont frappé avec la crosse du fusil
un bateau
ce que je vois là bas c'est bien les
membres de l'armée il traite les gens
n'importe comment quand il rentre dans
les villages ils fouillent tout le monde
ils détruisent tout leur véhicule écrase
nos maisons il garde tout toute ma
famille a été tuée
dans ma région quand tu es peu un temps
l'armée vient à la rose que tu sois un
homme une femme un enfant l'armée ne
tuent elles tuent indique que nous
sommes tous des terroristes
ou est ce
nous constatons à maintes reprises à
quel point les pratiques de gouvernement
malien depuis 2012 n'ont fait
qu'aggraver et intensifier le conflit
one d'abord par le fait qu'ils ferment
les yeux sur les exactions des milices
qui ont décidé de se faire justice
elle-même
ensuite par une politique anti
terroriste agressive et sous couvert de
laquelle des forces de sécurité
maliennes ont exécuté des centaines de
suspects en dehors de tout cadre
judiciaire
et non le gouvernement ne remplit pas
son rôle de protecteur des différentes
communautés ethniques au
[Musique]
le camp de faladié n'a cessé de
s'étendre en trois ans d'existence
pour apporter des soins à près de trois
mille déplacés il n'ya que ce petit
dispensaire tenu à bout de bras par une
poignée de volontaires
[Musique]
rapide pour fermer
aucune ong n'est présente au camp de
faladié les médicaments proviennent de
dons privés
le temps maussade n'a pas connu la même
s'ils savent et ne veulent pas
reconnaître qu'on a en effet des choses
plus on a fait des piliers qui vieillit
bob
l'état c'est pas facile d'aller
combattre comme ça ils ont une liste des
140 familles
nous on a 40 ans d
voyez la différence
donc tout cela et se méfie des mais
n'évitent pas comment ça un public
ce jeune peul et hébergés dans un
village du centre du pays il vient de
passer cinq ans en détention dans une
prison de bamako soupçonné d'appartenir
à un groupe djihadiste
faute de preuves il a été relâché
il souffre de troubles mentaux
lorsqu'elle est sortie en plus élevé
lessive on a pris sa photo pour publier
pour que je puisse avoir dans ses
parents choqués pour lui trouver quoi
vous avez trouvé dans la patrie blanc
c'est pour cela qu'il est là
nous donne à manger cru tout
[Musique]
alors qu'il faisait paître son troupeau
cet éleveur aurait été embarqué dans un
véhicule de l'armée malienne
elle a été agressée ce la route
qui sont les agresseurs
auraient moins d'engouement
l'amour n'a pas
d'autorité les forces et des hommes
c'est ce qu'il a dit oui
est ce qu il a des blessures
salah
hamouri n'a
été commis ou sa wiimote et
le pôle
le lieu
le jeune homme a été relâché dans la
nature sans suivi
la justice antiterroriste au mali ne
prévoit pas de programme de réinsertion
pour aider les anciens détenus à
reprendre une vie normale
à bamako un avocat a choisi de défendre
les dossiers de présumés jihadistes
offert aux exactions de l'armée
c'est dans le cadre de la lutte contre
le toulouse des militaires ont débarqué
dans son village une lampe lui c'est un
chef de village lui c'est un chef de
village
selon m hassan barry les prisons de
bamako sont remplis de personnes
détenues pour soupçon de terrorisme sans
preuves ni procès
l' amalgame a consisté ici à confondre
l'ethnie peule aux terroristes parce que
tout simplement hamadoun kouffars
aujourd'hui chef de la katiba du macina
et est un peu un peu le centre
l'amalgamme a été tellement
tellement moment du coup aujourd'hui il
quoi véritablement à sa lave l'armée a
besoin de résultats il faut justifier il
faut les chiffres nous avons arrêté un
nombre de personnes nous avons tué un
nombre de personnes nous avons éliminé
tel nombre de terroristes mais en fait
c'est pas des terroristes qu'ils
éliminent c'est des pauvres belgique qui
sont des liens des animaux qu'on confond
aux terroristes et celle à qui et qui
c'est extrêmement grave et c'est
extrêmement désolant
l' amalgame entre les peuls et les
djihadistes condamne de plus en plus
d'innocents à la prison ou à la mort
face à un état qui punit sans
discernement les villageois choisirait
de se plier aux règles des djihadistes
perçu comme plus justes
mais beaucoup de villageois parmi
lesquels des chefs peuls m'ont dit qu'il
se sentait mieux protégés par les
groupes armés que par l'état les
villageois me disent aussi que les
djihadistes sur le plan moral sont en
train de gagner la guerre dans certaines
zones parce que eux savent discipliner
leurs trous s'attaquer au banditisme et
ils rendent la justice c'est un grave
problème pour l'état
[Musique]
dès leur putsch en 2020 les militaires
ont dit avoir entendu la colère du
peuple contre la corruption du régime et
l'insécurité galopante
ils ont donné des gages de changements
aux soldats du pays
par exemple en se recueillant devant les
corps de militaires tués au combat lors
d'une cérémonie d'hommage à cathy
un événement rare ces dernières années
l'ancien gouvernement considérant le
rapatriement des dépouilles à la
capitale comme trop coûteux
[Musique]
la junte a aussi promis d'organiser des
élections cours en 2022
mais neuf mois après le coup d'état les
militaires interviennent une nouvelle
fois dans le jeu politique
en mai 2021 il évince le président et le
premier ministre par intérim qu'ils
avaient eux mêmes placés aux affaires
les putschistes donne l'impression de ne
pas vouloir céder le pouvoir
la france cherche depuis des mois un
moyen de sortir du bourbier malien alors
elle voit dans ce deuxième coup d'état à
l'occasion de rapatrier une partie des
5100 soldats présents sur place
emmanuel macron annonce la fermeture de
trois des six bases françaises du mali à
kidal tessalit t tombouctou les troupes
de barkan seront diminuer d'au moins 40%
d'ici 2023
le président français le répète depuis
plus d'un an c'est à l'état malien de
prendre ses responsabilités
sans la france au sahel il n'y aurait
plus de gouvernement au mali je vous le
dis très nettement il faut que l'état
revienne avec sa justice son éducation
sa police partout particulier au mali
aussi au burkina il faut que derrière
les projets se développent sinon dès
qu'on libère un territoire les
terroristes reprennent mais il n'y a pas
de perspective est donc l'armée
française n'a pas se substituer aux noms
travail si je puis dire de l'état malien
et doit y revenir
et donc nous nous reconcentrer on nous à
la fois géographiquement en termes de
missions sur la stricte lutte contre les
groupes terroristes au mali le retrait
progressif de barkan est perçu comme une
décision unilatérale
alors à la tribune de l'onu le nouveau
premier ministre malien nommé par les
militaires menace la france d'aller
chercher du soutien ailleurs
de mal il regrette que le principe de
consultation et de concertation qui doit
être la règle entre partenaires
privilégiés n'est pas été observé en
amont de la décision du gouvernement
français aussi la nouvelle situation née
de la fin de barkan place à le mali
devant le fait accompli et l'exposera il
a une espèce d'abandon en plein vol nous
conduit à explorer les voies et moyens
pour mieux assurer la sécurité de
manière autonome avec d'autres
partenaires
les mots de choguel maïga confirmé une
rumeur qui court depuis des semaines
entre bamako et paris celle d'une
alliance militaire avec la russie
les dirigeants maliens serait en train
de négocier un accord avec une société
privée de mercenaires russes wagner
présents en syrie et en ukraine wagner
opère déjà dans neuf pays africains où
ces mercenaires violent et exécutent
sommairement des civils
des liens avec la russie existe déjà
depuis des années le mali lui achète des
équipements militaires comme des
hélicoptères des armes et les munitions
mais pour la france l'onu et les
européens une alliance avec les russes
serait un affront
les experts sont plus nuancés en
brandissant la menace de l'allié russe
les maliens chercherait des
contreparties retrait français c'est
plutôt une façon de mettre un peu la
pression sur la france et de
négocier certaines choses que ce soit
les modalités du soutien futur
français que ça soit le dispositif que
la france reste laisse au mali ou pas ce
que ce soit le partage de renseignements
que ce soit la durée de la transition
le véritable enjeu ici c'est que faut
que l'armée malienne se prennent en main
il faut qu'ils ne veulent monter pauli 2
c'est que la sécurité de pia avance et
c'est pas nécessairement les partenaires
étrangers qui que ce soit qui va être
capable de l'un se fait dans les forces
armées maliennes
[Musique]
la stratégie du tout sécuritaire prenait
depuis dix ans au mallié par les
décideurs politiques occidentaux montre
aujourd'hui ses limites
très coûteuse des interventions
extérieures sont surtout inadaptée au
contexte malien est de plus en plus
décrié par la population
[Musique]
seule une reconstruction complète de
l'état pourra guérir les plaies du mali
c'est la conviction de clément dembélé
le militant anticorruption a décidé de
créer son parti pour se lancer en
politique
[Musique]
la collision est le mensonge d'état soit
devenu un phénomène culturel j'initie
devoir refuser l'évidence que le malien
est génétiquement quoi
clément des mails et à l'ambition de
moderniser la vie politique malienne à
commencer par la rendre plus
transparente
il pousse ses concitoyens à agir comme
lanceur d'alerté a dénoncé sans crainte
les corrompus populaire auprès des
jeunes clément d'aimer les plaies pour
son franc parler le mali a atteint un
niveau aujourd'hui où on parle plus de
pollution on parle de voile à ciel
ouvert et des pillages à ciel ouvert
dans un état où il ya la corruption la
justice corrompue dans nos colonnes les
forces de l'ordre corrompus dans un état
où il ya les services minimums sociaux
de base ne sont pas là dans un pays où
il n'ya pas de route où l'agent qui doit
être mise à l'eau tout cas l'union
européenne ou la banque mondiale paix
pouvait la route on détourne hommage et
il est apparu tout la zone peu il ya pas
de paul pour les enfants puissent aller
à l'école on a passé trois ans oui
bécassin du col
quand il ya des gens qui viennent qui se
présente à ces villageois pour leur
donner un peu de médicaments un peu
d'eau et qui essaie de dire au nom de la
charia que la justice soit faite
qu'est-ce que vous voulez que ces gens
facile mais il faut qu'on comprenne
aujourd'hui que le problème des dialyses
de tourisme est liée à l'état malien et
tout vient de beaucoup le problème
malien est un problème inventée au mali
est alimenté par des dirigeants maliens
et la solution et les maliennes et
viendra pas d'ailleurs les hôtes peuvent
vous soutenez que ce soit balkanes que
ce soit là mais française que ce soit
l'amusement ce soit des maliens qui doit
régler des problèmes de tous les points
de malice à bamako ici
au mali clément dembélé n'est pas le
seul à le penser l'avenir du pays ne
dépend pas d intervention étrangère
le retour au pouvoir des talibans en
afghanistan malgré vingt ans de présence
américaine résonne ici comme un
avertissement
on peut probablement attiré quelques
instructions du kafka afghane
surtout dans les dernières semaines ce
qu on a commencé à nîmes on sait quand
même que si la politique ne tient pas la
route
l'outil militaire avant pas à tenir la
route en plus
la victoire des talibans en afghanistan
semblent avoir déjà inspiré les groupes
islamistes armés tout du moins ceux qui
sont alliés à al-qaïda rideuses
je parle avec des dizaines de villageois
qui m'ont décrit comment ils ont perdu
toute confiance en leur état à cause de
la corruption de ses fonctionnaires
ils décrivent aussi commandant leur
rassemblement les islamistes parle de
corruption cette corruption du
gouvernement malien qu'il compare à leur
propre gouvernance
selon moi le parallèle clé entre les
deux pays c'est le manque d'attention de
la communauté internationale face à la
corruption
afin d'éviter un scénario à l'afghane
les autorités maliennes aimerait ouvrir
des négociations avec les djihadistes
l'idée n'est pas nouvelle et elle ne
fait pas l'unanimité au mali de son côté
la france s'y oppose fermement
pour elle c'est toujours l'option
militaire qui prime la preuve la france
place tous ses espoirs dans takouba une
force spéciale composée de militaires
européens censé prendre la suite de
barkan
huit ans après le début de la guerre
c'est la sixième intervention militaire
extérieure que connaît le mali
[Musique]
pourquoi